votre grand journal du soir sur europe 1
à 19 heures jean c'est l'interview
politique nathalie levy avec votre
invité david dos quand bruno retailleau
ce soir bonsoir bruno retailleau
danseurs david du camp alors vous avez
la semaine dernière en fin de semaine
dernière déposé une proposition de loi
pour interdire les listes
communautariste aux élections en france
bruno retailleau sur quels fondements
juridiques et constitutionnelles repose
votre proposition de loi sur deux
principes constitutionnels
je m'étonne que quelques juristes est
oublier que notre droit notre
constitution n'est pas du tout mettre
sur le communautarisme je m'appuie sur
d'abord la laïcité la laïcité parce que
le conseil constutionnel dans les années
2006 très exactement à 10 et l adn de la
république il échappait même voyez au
contrôle de la cour européenne de
justice à vous faites référence à la
jurisprudence les juges ont appris dans
absolument ce jury j'adore décision
c'est notre identité constitutionnel
deuxièmement deuxième mouvement la
souveraineté nationale monsieur erdogan
ne peut pas activer des partis
politiques en france qui ne sont que le
faux nez de la cap et en turquie ça
c'est de l'extérieur mais la
souveraineté nationale l'article 3
l'article iv nous apprend qu'il s'agit
en fait privilégier non pas tout le
peuple de france français mais une
section du peuple notamment à raison d'
appartenance ethnique ou religieuse dans
ces conditions bruno retailleau ce
principe de souveraineté qui est le
fondement de votre proposition de loi
est ce que jean guy talamoni
indépendantiste corse va pouvoir
continuer à se présenter aux élections
ils peuvent puisque la constitution rhdp
d'abord il ne menace pas la laïcité et
en matière de souveraineté nationale
la constitution prévoit un certain
nombre de points on parle même d'ouvrir
d'ailleurs l'article 72 à la
reconnaissance de la corse en tant que
tel là où monsieur talamoni pourrait
être répréhensible si d'un point de vue
national il ne s'adressait qu'à une
partie du peuple français alexis l'ample
le parti breton par exemple et sur leur
site internet tout à l'heure
le parti breton prône l'émancipation du
peuple breton par la volonté des bretons
vous remplacez le mot breton par
musulmans le monde
parti breton pourrait résider aux
élections si votre loi est adoptée bien
sûr mais c'est exactement comme le
peuple kanak le peuple kanak eux
revendiquent par exemple une séparation
il revendique une indépendance sauf que
la constitution le prévoit
donc on n'a pas de problème juridique
constitutionnel puisque là une
différence bien sûr qu'il n'y firent les
revendications et les broderies les
bretons ne menace pas non plus la
laïcité française
donc je crois que ce qui est important
le communautarisme je pense donne une
définition c'est le fait de privilégier
en réalité une catégorie de français à
raison de l'origine ethnique et moi j'ai
dit laïc c'est à dire religieuse
bon donc pour vous les corps ça rentre
pas dans cette définition et sauf au
moment sauf si demain les corses avaient
démener sur une élection nationale qui
pourrait menacer
comment dirais-je la laïcité ou la
souveraineté nationale bruno retailleau
ya une question qui se pose est ce que
vous voulez interdire les listes
communautaire parce que vous considérez
que vous ne pouvez pas les battre est ce
que est ce que les partis républicains
ont baissé les armes certains la gauche
extrême à baisser les armes
on l'a vu ce week-end ce week-end
lorsque encadrés par des islamistes ils
se sont rendus à cette manifestation
c'est pour moi un os frage de cette
partie de la gauche pas de toute la
gauche mais souvent pour des raisons
électorales n'étaient simplement les
joueurs contre idec
comme le veut je considère sdc pâle
jayas il faut les combats bien reçus et
collez gabarit c'est un combat avec
notre droit ok comment dire que tout
construit c'est qu'on a peur de perdre
non quand notre constitution ne
reconnaît notre démocratie ne reconnaît
que ceux qui se reconnaissent dans les
valeurs de la république et de la
démocratie
pour moi c'est absolument clair et
demain parce que vous savez que
notamment un ministre du gouvernement a
dit mais finalement faut pas légiférer
avant lorsqu'ils seront élus sera
toujours temps de les révoquer sébastien
lecornu vous en ag de lutte et
erythréens mer frérot salafistes élus en
france vous lui arracher
le bandeau bleu blanc rouge la cocarde
bleu blanc rouge qu'est ce qui se passe
bah il se passe que ce mr la
communautariste fait appel à sa
communauté et ça se termine par des
affrontements
donc je pense qu'il vaut mieux prévenir
que guérir écoutez ce matin en face de
monsieur castaner on avait un
intellectuel qui s'appelle bernard oger
qui sort un livre les territoires
conquis par l'islamisme le constat que
cet intellectuel a fait en france que
n'a pas démenti et monsieur castaner ni
même belloubet ni monsieur laurent nunez
il est terrible il est même stupéfiant
donc où on mène le combat qu'on doit
mener contre ceux qui demain vont
menacer notre liberté
le principe d'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes non mais où eux-mêmes ce
combat une retenue on capitule et bien
non je ne veux pas qu'on capitule c'est
interdire ces capitaux parce que bien
sûr mais on y remédier bruno revenir
il ya la quantité il ya quantité j'ai
aujourd'hui en france des nazis et c'est
qu'ils sont interdits ont aimé vous
dites demain un maire frérot musulmans
salafistes salle rose salafistes
salafistes si on oui bien sûr si on
regarde les résultats aux européennes de
l'ue dms est le grand maximum à
garges-lès-gonesse par exemple ils ont
fait 7 % mais vous savez parfaitement ce
qui a pas un candidat les républicains
qui en capacité da par le débat
politique par le l'engagement de vaincre
ce que ce qui effectivement peuvent
représenter une manne à des règles
heureuse la démocratie oui mais les
règles de la démocratie pour des
candidats qui se reconnaissent dans les
valeurs de la démocratie et de la
république il n'y a pas de place pour
ceux qui sous terraines mans combattent
les principes de la république
un choses doivent être claires parce que
ce serait trop dangereux pour notre
démocratie et la république
aujourd'hui certes il ne menace pas la
france entière ils menacent quelques
communes mais demain ce sera trop tard
moi je préfère encore une fois prévenir
que guérir parce que si demain on
laissait passer ces gens là à ce moment
là croyez-moi y aurait des violences en
france c'est un combat et et l'islam
politique ce que je veux dire notamment
nos compatriotes musulmans c'est que
l'islamisme c'est pas une religion
l'islamisme c'est une idéologie
politique qui utilisent qui dévoient une
religion l'islam des voiliers dié
la mac ne ment donc il faut faire le tri
et moi je le fais y compris pour nos
compatriotes musulmans qui pratiquent un
islam apaisé mais croyez moi aujourd'hui
quand l'ancien président république
françois hollande par les deux
partitions quand le ministre d'intérieur
disait qu'on risquait de se trouver
demain face à face quand vous avez deux
instituts l'institut notamment jean
jaurès et puis l'institut montagne à
deux années vous avez deux études qui
montrent que pratiquement un tiers de
nos compatriotes musulmans pensent que
la charia la loi religieuse est au
dessus de la loi de république
ça vous a folle pas j'ai trouvé ce boisé
à vue j'ai restauré sa note très inquiet
alors justement vous l'avez vous a vu
ministre de l'intérieur sur ce sujet ce
matin christophe qatar ont dit qu'il
était très inquiet en réalité vous
partager l'objectif de combattre l'islam
politique
vous n'êtes pas d'accord sur les moyens
à employer le gouvernement nous dit on
ne peut pas interdire les gens d'être
candidat dans une démocratie
en revanche pas en revanche si je vous
dis ce que dit le gouvernement vous vous
allez répondre
en revanche il y a la possibilité pour
les préfets pour le gouvernement de 2,2
de sanctionner de révoquer un maire qui
prendrait des arrêtés qu'ils sont
contraires à nos valeurs voilà ce que
dit le gouvernement se fera pas et ça se
fera dans des conditions de violence
tant qu'il faut le faire avant vous
savez il ya un grand parti en france
qu'est le parti de l'impossibilité c'est
pas possible le droit nous l'interdît
moi je le connais ce parti à chaque fois
qu'on veut légiférer de façon ferme
c'était le cas sur la burqa en 2010 on
nous avait prédit que c'était un
conditionnel ça a été approuvé par
conséquent sionnel myriam el khomri
souvenez vous elle fait passer dans la
loi travail en arctique qui permet aux
entreprises dans le règlement intérieur
d'imposer la neutralité religieuse
on nous a dit select'om ans à tout
demande qu'on cite mais si monsieur
bianco qui était président qui est
président de cherves à thouars dans les
cités dit mais c'est anti concessionnels
les employeurs doivent trouver d aider d
mais prêté je sais que je veux dit qu'à
chaque fois qu'on veut être ferme en
france il ya ce grand parti de
l'impossibilité qui dit c'est pas
possible faut pas bouger donc on a
partagé un même diagnostic qui est
terrible avec monsieur castaner
maintenant il ya les remèdes
est ce que le gouvernement veut livrer
ce combat
quel combat pour la république dont
j'espère que oui je pense que quand
j'entends le premier ministre à
l'assemblée cet après-midi répondants
damien bad nouvellement élu à la tête du
groupe parlementaire des députés l air
j'en doute fortement
il ya un choix ce choix il est soit la
fermeté soit l'ambiguïté insertion ne
livre pas ce combat
croyez moi c'est la république qui sera
ébranlée alors à moyen terme justement
la république on la sent menacé un peu
tout par un dernier point bruno route et
vous avez vu l'ancien président françois
hollande devait tenir une conférence à
la faculté à lille n'a pas pu le faire
n'a pas pu tenir sa conférence parce que
des militants ont envahi la salle avant
qu'il n'arrive un je le précise sa
sécurité n'a pas été mise en cause
ils ont rejeté au sol ses livres il y
avait eu sylviane agacinski l os qui
récemment empêchés de parler quel regard
portez-vous là dessus un regard d'une
grande inquiétude pourquoi parce que
historiquement depuis des siècles
l'université est le lieu privilégié est
le lieu par excellence de la
conversation de la dispute du débat et
on voit bien qu'ils aient une
radicalisation que le débat devient de
moins en moins possible vous l'avez site
et sylviane agacinski à bordeaux mohamed
sifaoui aussi qui a écrit un excellent
bouquin qui s'appelle taqiyya sur la
stratégie des frères musulmans interdit
à la sorbonne et là c'est françois
l'orne franchement françois hollande
gelé combattu moi parce que c'était un
opposant politique mais il était
président de la république française les
bras m'en sont tombés
je demande solennellement au
gouvernement et à la ministre des
universités d'y mettre bon ordre
quelle sanction très belle ville auront
bien sûr je vais même vous révéler un
point qui ne l'a pas été il ya quelques
jours il ya dix jours je suis intervenu
auprès de frédéric vidal parce que j'ai
su qu'un grand colloque qui devait se
passer dans grand amphi à jussieu n'a
pas pu se passer à jussieu un colloque
international vous m'entendez bien sûr
le terrorisme on en est là en france
l'université qui devrait être le lieu
privilégié du débat devient un lieu du
sectarisme appelle la ministre doit
prendre des sanctions très rapidement
pour préserver cette possibilité de ce
que j'appelle la conversation civique
la dispute intellectuelle l'appel
solennel et lancé bruno retailleau merci
d'avoir accepté mon invitation
europe 1
[Musique]